does that I agree exactly with what you
just said and so what I the view that
I've come to in study moral psychology
is that we is that humans are ultra
social Apes we we evolved to live in
these small groups that are fighting
with each other we evolved to have these
low-level animistic religions that's our
steady-state that's the way we were for
at least 100,000 years or much more
close are a million in some form so
that's sort of our design that's what we
were designed for in a sense and in that
sense where as individuals we really
kind of stupid tribal creatures designed
to do post hoc reasoning but if you put
us together in the right way with the
right checks with the right the right
systems the the whole can be vastly
smarter than the components that go into
it
which is true of the brain - the brain
is composed of neurons each neurons
really a kind of a stupid little switch
but you put them together in the right
way and you get something really
brilliant and in the same way I don't
know all the history here but my
understanding is that science begins or
the culture of science the scientific
revolution begins in Europe in the 17th
century as you begin getting you get the
printing press so people can share their
ideas but you get communities of people
who are challenging each other's ideas
and that's what makes it so brilliant is
that is that people have to do their
best we're really bad at disconfirming
our own ideas it's very hard to make
it's very hard to do that but you put
your ideas out there and then everyone
else is motivated to challenge them and
so if you put us together in the right
way the truth comes out and so
adversarial systems of law journalists
know this they have to listen to both
sides scientists know this social
scientists should know this